rafi on the league uh hilarious
character but
good god the lines they have you saying
and that you say
are some of the worst things i've ever
heard come out of any
human character in the history of the
television medium here's the sad reality
that show is improvised so
they're not making me say any of them
i'm doing it all to myself yeah and so
anything i get back
if people on the street while i'm like
walking like with somebody that i'm
dating or somebody
if somebody wants to walk by and scream
like sometimes i
when i which is a line
which is a line that i have said on the
show
we can say that on tv right
which just full you said you said that
on your show yeah
yeah and now i've said it on your show
you've said it on this show i just gotta
get it on a couple of other shows
yeah kind of a detective munch situation
andy and i have ended up barbara walters
retired yeah he'll come down
a minute and i have to call our parents
before this show airs
that's not true i don't
when i do that i don't do the other i do
them
singularly in different
places
all right all right so those are the
kind of things people shout at you when
you're walking oh yeah sweet
yeah or if you're like with an old lady
find each other's
off
if uh because i don't know if they're
holding one
are you quoting once in the show now or
do you have tourette
like you can just you can just
that's how it feels like it's it's that
invasive because
you're you're not expecting it you're
still talking to me like normal and it's
then somebody is
is just like finish him
oh my gosh so you're just eating gelato
somewhere always the enchilada
face in and says yeah oh oh um let me
think of another one that's really
really horrible oh worse than what
you've already said
oh my god oh this is one that people
really love and say all the time which
is
because they think it's hilarious to
them because they think we're all going
to get involved in it which is
let's all get the same girl pregnant
tonight
that's not possible oh hang on i want to
explain to you how that might happen
okay
let's just say the four of us are out
for an evening
okay it's like an evening of leisure
yeah we all meet the same lady
we all lay with her and then as a kind
of
cocktail of man stuff
are you with me on this i'm i'm with
your i mean i think this is the same
stuff that's on wilfred right
sure i feel like i want rafi to start
appearing on other shows now
oh yeah i want that oh yeah we're gonna
see yeah i can't wait to see rafi on the
view yeah
pretty little
i wish bun heads was still on
amy sherman palladino call me i want to
talk about it
all right you you're an awful awful man
yeah get it out there
get it out there i was right to
mispronounce your name
uh they came together i i can't believe
i know i'm transitioning they did indeed
[Laughter]
romantic
oh thank you that's yours now you do
you've earned it you've earned that fake
microphone first i've never seen that
happen
yeah that's a big you can't really keep
it because it's worth money uh